We're going to create two relationships.
One that goes from notebook to note and
another one which goes
from note to notebook.
In order for
Core Data to work its magic, it's vital
that we always set both relationships.
One way and then back.
There's a big difference
between both relationships.
Notebook, which we will
create here is one-to-one,
which means that one note
can only be in one notebook.
Notes is one-to-many, which means that
one notebook can have several notes.
Let's stop for a moment and think how
these relationships will be mapped
once the entity is turned into a class.
A one-to-one relationship,
such as a notebook,
will become a property of type notebook.
So far so good.
What will happen to notes?
It will become a property of type set.
A set similar to an array but
it with a few limitations.
There's no order and
no object can be repeated.
Now that we have both
relationships created,
let's make sure that we have both,
the direct relationship and the inverse.
This is a very important step.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And back to notebook.
We need to make sure that the
relationship goes from note to notebook.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And now
We have the two relationships correct.
Now, move on to the next video once
you've added the relationships to your
data model.
[BLANK_AUDIO]